il va déménager oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe
il faut pas que d'arrêt puis des mois
mais non bien sûr que non tu travaille
je travaille je suis un homme comme les
autres
vous n'allez pas d'y voir si on arrête
avec ça coûte pourquoi divorceraient tu
vois bien concept avéré moi il y avait
quand même des critères physiques qui
était important pour nous parce qu'on ne
peut pas retrouver dans la vraie vie il
est très exacte d'une bd mais c'était
intéressant d'avoir un gamin qui est une
bonne tête des bonnes joues donc ça
charles l'avait une chevelure magnifique
c'est un vrai petit roux avec une peau
blanche parisien il a une photogénie
extraordinaire l'enfant charles qui a 9
ans lui a dû rencontrer bill le samedi
ou le mercredi au préalable du tournage
pour qu'il puisse s'acclimater découvrir
leur personnalité à l'un et à l'autre et
d'avoir une complexité
c'est un énorme boulot pour un pour un
enfant le tournage a quand même duré ya
plus deux semaines on peut pas demander
à un enfant d'être bon à chaque prise
devant tout le temps ce sont des moments
magiques ou tout à coup sûr une prise il
va être ce qu'on veut il doit être bien
sûr que nous effectivement il faut qu'on
soit magique
à ce moment là aussi parce que c'est
l'enfant qui primera il sera pas magique
trois fois
mais gary était tout seul et il
débarquer dans un monde d'adultes quoi
donc il a il a été hyper courageux il
nous a donné ce que ce qu on se convainc
voulait et puis surtout quand on le voit
avec le chien c'est vraiment c'est boule
et bill quoi joue vraiment un problème
avec les promenades dans cette famille
alors qu'est ce que vous venez danser
m